Hey youtubers it’s Charlie and because comic
con put me behind this is going to be my Teen
Wolf episode 6 and 7 video. I’m mostly going
to focus on Episode 7 just because there was
some really important stuff but I will mention
the really important takeaways from last week.
If you’re just finding me for the first
time I do Teen Wolf every week. Be sure to
subscribe to get everything. At the end of
this video I’ll say who won the comic con
giveaway.
So let’s get going. Careful for spoilers
from episodes 6 and 7 if you haven’t seen
them yet. I’ll wait just a sec...okay, here
we go.
Most important stuff from episode 6. Peter
and Kate are going to be working together.
Kate controls the Berserkers but it seems
like neither she or Peter are connected to
the Benefactor in a conscious way.
Previously I had thought Peter was a good
candidate as a way to get his Alpha powers
back but now it seems like he’s just one
of the victims and is making lemonade with
all the lemons trying to kill him.
Meredith flips her shit when Lydia presses
her for the last cypher key, but before she
killed herself she said “he doesn’t want
me to tell you”. Meaning she has been in
communication with whoever he is. Notice she
said “he” too, so it’s not a woman.
And Derek being the last cypher key was a
pretty big WTF. They said it was someone who
would be dead. So the last portion of the
list hasn’t been circulated to all the mercenaries.
The whole messages on a mixtape thing is a
bit strange and I wonder if the Benefactor
is using that old timey method of communication
to stay off the net or if it’s an affectation.
Like him circulating the tapes ties in to
his character traits.
Moving on to Episode 7, I’m going to do
this just like I normally do with TOP 5 WTF
Moments and a longer review. So here we go.
Number 5 - Satomi isn’t Dead
I loved her introduction. It was straight
out of a Kung Fu fight movie. Slow Motion
martial arts fight in heavy rain. This reminded
me of a movie called The Grandmaster, that’s
about IP Man one of the real life greatest
Kung Fu masters to ever live. The whole opening
scene of that movie is an epic battle in the
rain.
It’s on netflix so you should watch it immediately
It feels like she’s going to become a bigger
part of the story this season and help them
take down the benefactor. I could definitely
see her sacrificing herself for Scott’s
pack. Her own pack is all dead, so unless
she creates a new beta or starts working with
Derek there’s not a lot left for her to
do on the show.
Number 4 - Coach Used to be a Drunk
So this was the backne reveal. That’s what
I thought when she pulled his shirt up. If
you were confused about how the virus worked.
It would put everyone down for a little while.
But non-were creatures would just automatically
get better after a short period of time.
So that’s why coach just shot up and asked
what the hell was going on.
Lydia’s Mom was so cool during this. Most
of the time when we see her she’s being
completely ridiculous. But we find out when
things start to slide downhill that she really
cares about everyone, especially coach. Who
I guess used to be a crazy drunk?
Alcohol and substance abuse are big problems
for celebrities or athletes that get their
careers torpedoed by injuries. Remember, Coach
was a big athlete that just never made it.
I can’t remember if they explained why.
I always love it when they reveal big character
details for minor characters. And how cute
was it that when Lydia came in her mother
immediately pretended to be ridiculous again.
I think she did that just to make Lydia feel
more comfortable.
Number 3 - Stiles Wants to Keep The Money
This got pretty dark. It almost made me think
Stiles was in on the Deadpool list somehow.
Just the language that he used. And how passionate
he got about not rushing to give the money
over to Peter and Derek.
Even Scott was confused by his behavior. The
Eichenhouse money thing has been teased this
season just like Scott’s Mom going bankrupt
and losing the house.
There’s two practical outcomes. The hero
option, Stiles and Scott just suck it up,
give the money over to Derek and look for
overtime work to help pay off their debts.
Heroes don’t steal. Think of it like “What
would Captain America do?”
The
other morally ambiguous option is that they
give Derek part of the money and keep the
other half to pay the bills.
Because of the trust issues going on with
Malia in the episode I don’t see Stiles
pushing as hard for this. If he took the money
and Peter found out, it would just be more
ammo to drive a wedge between Malia and the
pack.
Eventually Peter is going to surround himself
with more allies as he grows more powerful.
So he’s going to try and coerce Malia at
some point. If she doesn’t just rush over
to the loft immediately for answers.
Number 2 - PSAT Guy is Infecting Everyone
As crazy as him holding the gun against Stiles
head I think that guy’s introduction in
the creepy basement was worse. If you weren’t
sure what he was doing, he was testing the
virus to see how long it took to kill a werewolf.
That’s why he left that guy on the hospital
bed inside the ring of mountain ash.
The whole virus subplot was an interesting
homage to Cabin Fever or any infection movie
you can think of. I’m a bigger fan of movies
that take place in the aftermath of big outbreaks,
like Walking Dead. But I like how Teen Wolf
can do genres within genres.
It’s a show about werewolves first, but
getting meta with other genres just gives
you so many places to go with stories.
It seems like a lot of these deapool mercenaries
get one episode arcs, or really short ones.
There’s only a few episodes left, so I wonder
if the mercenaries we run into next will just
be progressively bigger and badder until we
get to that final boss fight.
Like Scott’s pack is playing Mike Tyson’s
Punch Out and they just have to get through
all the bosses before they can fight Mike
Tyson.
and my Number 1 WTF Moment - Malia Learns
the Truth about Peter
I was pretty surprised by the way she found
out. I had expected her and Stiles relationship
to not be a part of the reveal. But we always
knew she’d find out at some point. And then
they did the whole ‘hiding things’ moment
with Kira.
The big question now is what will she do after
she gets the full story from Peter and will
Peter create some fiction to keep her close.
It seems like Scott and the others would have
explained Peter to her. Mostly that he can’t
be trusted and he’s a terrible person.
That’s the logical thing, but at Comic Con
when someone asked Jeff Davis about Malia
learning to do her hair and makeup, he waved
his hand and said TV Rules. He was pretty
open about saying the writers hoped fans would
give them a pass at the logic of Malia learning
to be a normal girl.
For the most part I don’t mind, but I hope
they don’t wave their hands too much at
the logic when it comes to Peter and Malia.
She’s pissed about Scott and the other’s
not telling her the truth, but that shouldn’t
make her forget what an awful person Peter
is.
But let me know what your biggest WTF from
the episode was and do you think that Malia
will go be with Peter or will she just run
off into the woods?
I think the show teased us way too much with
a Peter Malia moment so I definitely think
we’ll see that. But I think in the end,
Malia will betray Peter to help Stiles and
the pack before the end.
Whatever ends up happening with the Benefactor,
Peter will have his own side scheme. It will
probably involve dicking over Derek and everyone
else. And I feel like Malia will do the right
thing when she’s put in a situation where
she has to choose.
I mean she’s gotta come back
before season 5, who’s going going to spoon
stiles? Maybe Derek I guess?
They actually did that in an episode of family
guy, where Peter and Quagmire have to spoon
because Lois doesn’t want to anymore.
Overall I gave the episode a solid B. It had
a couple of great left turns with Satomi and
Malia. Stiles just got way more complicated.
Scott is the Captain America of the group,
he’ll always try to do the right thing.
Stiles on the other hand feels like Bucky.
He’s even been brainwashed before like Bucky
during season 3b.
Wouldn’t it be crazy if Stiles and Scott
had a falling out over the money. This season
is supposed to be all about human issues.
And fighting over money is a very human thing
to do.
I also really like how they paired people
up in this episode. Like putting Derek with
Braeden, Lydia’s Mom with the students,
Malia and Kira.
I tend to favor the light and funny stories.
Like the Lacrosse stuff, Malia trying to be
human, Scott and Kira relationship humor.
Lydia and Deputy Parrish. So when we get more
intense episodes like this one I always look
really hard for the lighter moments. Like
the Satomi reveal. It swung from crazy Hong
Kong fight movie to hey what’s up in a few
seconds.
And Kira fumbling over her words when it comes
to her and Scott. It’s like the whole episode
was a slow heart attack, so fun moments like
those are very appreciated.
And since it is the halfway point of the season
I feel like all the remaining episodes are
going to be a slow heart attack.
Let me know if you guys agree, do you like
the fun episodes more or do you like it more
when things get intense and you feel like
your heart is going to burst inside your chest?
Congrats to Karen C you're the comic con giveaway
winner!
So quick personal update. I just quit my job
to become a full time youtuber and my last
day is in a couple weeks. I’m also moving
at the end of the month too. So I’m trying
to make my video schedule as normal as possible.
So Teen Wolf should always post by Tuesday
for the rest of the season. But you can follow
me on social for updates in case something
weird happens.
I’m really excited about finally making
videos all the time but comic con felt like
a slow heart attack. In the best possible
way.
Right now click here for the Teen Wolf comic
con panel if you haven’t seen it yet and
click here for my episode 5 video.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tomorrow.
high fives!